لا وما رميت اذا رميت ولكن الله
رمى اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم كتائب القسام تخوض
اشتباكات مع قوات الاحتلال في خانيونس
جنوب قطاع غزه وتعلن استهداف دبابه وناقله
جند وسرايا القدس تقصف يروت ونير عام
بالصواريخ في حين اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
سحب كتيبه من القطاع وتجدون المزيد من
اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتع الاول
الخارجيه الامريكيه توافق على امكانيه بيع
تركيا 40 مقاتله من طراز اف 16 وتحديث
اخرين اضافه الى معدات ذات صله بنحو 23
مليار دولار حيث يتزامن هذا مع اجواء
موافقه تركيا على انضمام السويد الى
النيتو مصدر بالجيش السوداني يقول للجزيره
ان الجيش هاجم تجمعات لقوات الدعم السريع
في منطقه الكدو شمالي مدينه الخرطوم بحر
حيث تمكن من السيطره على مقر للدعم السريع
وان اشتباكات عنيفه تدور بين الجانبين
بمشاركه الطيران الحربي ترامب يتعرض
لهزيمه قاسيه بعد ان امرته هيئه محلفين في
ولايه نيويورك بدفع تعويضات قيمتها 83
مليون دولار الى صحفيه قالت انه دمر
سمعتها وثقه الناس بها من خلال انكاره انه
اغتصبها قبل عقود الى
اللقاء
l